rien de la prédestiné à devenir député
mon invité n'avait ni la bonne carte
d'identité ni forcément l'ambition mais
elle a découvert tardivement que
l'engagement politique faisait partie de
l'histoire de sa famille une histoire
secrète
[Musique]
bonjour Soumia bouroua bonjour Clément
Méric alors pendant longtemps vous avez
regardé la politique un peu comme un
enfant regarderait un gros gâteau auquel
il aurait pas droit de toucher tout
simplement parce que vous ne pouviez pas
voter alors que vous étiez quand même
très attiré par par la politique oui je
ne pouvais pas voter parce que je
n'avais pas la nationalité française je
suis né je suis né à Ghazaouet en
Algérie et et j'ai demandé ma
naturalisation très tardivement voilà en
effet ça a été une grande frustration
c'est à dire vous vous avez des
souvenirs précis qui évoquent un peu ce
cela alors les souvenirs c'est en effet
pour obtenir enfin pour pouvoir habiter
en France et aller à l'école et
travailler en France il faut une carte
de séjour donc j'étais obligée d'aller
régulièrement dès l'âge de 16 ans il me
semble à la préfecture de Bobigny pour
faire la queue de 4 heures du matin avec
une ouverture à 9 heures et ça a été
très très compliqué à vivre je vivais ça
comme une injustice parce que dans ma
famille j'étais la seule à ne pas avoir
la nationalité française la
présidentielle de 1981
vous vous pouviez pas voter vos frères
et sœurs pouvaient vous les avez même
alors oui en quelque sorte oui oui j'ai
suivi toute la campagne de des
présidentielles mais malheureusement je
ne pouvais pas voter parce que je
n'avais pas la nationalité française par
contre mes frères et soeur avaient la
nationalité donc je les encourageais et
j'ai le souvenir de les titiller toute
la journée du dimanche en disant
attention ils attendaient toujours la
dernière minute pour y aller et je les
accompagnais mais c'est aussi peut-être
pour moi une façon de de m'impliquer de
comme si c'était un vote par procuration
et en effet je les accompagnais et je
restais dans la salle et je et j'aimais
bien ce à voter vous l'avez évoqué vous
avez été naturalisé française à l'âge de
31 ans et
là pendant des années il a fallu aller
renouveler vos papiers Votre titre de
séjour alors que vous pour vous la
France était votre pays vous vous
projetiez un avenir français entre
guillemets comment est-ce que vous avez
vécu cela c'était
ce décalage entre votre statut et ce que
vous viviez vous personnellement je l'ai
vécu véritablement comme une comme une
injustice je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
j'étais pas intégré comme mes frères et
sœurs en effet mais mes frères et sœurs
sont tous nés en France moi je suis
celle du centre la quatrième et mes
parents sont dans leur histoire ont dû
retourner en Algérie pour après
l'indépendance de l'Algérie avec
l'espoir d'une vie meilleure et je suis
née à ce moment-là donc en effet j'ai
vécu ça comme une injustice je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi alors que
j'étais scolarisée comme comme n'importe
quel enfant de France pourquoi je ne
pouvais pas accéder
à cette naturalisation naturelle et
d'office vos parents eux-mêmes se
projetaient pas forcément en France ils
vous ont longtemps dit que toute la
famille allait repartir en Algérie alors
que vous c'était pas du tout votre rêve
on l'a bien compris comment est-ce que
vous avez vécu ce décalage avec vos le
désir profond de vos parents
alors en effet c'était très c'était
assez compliqué à vivre parce qu'on
avait toujours le sentiment d'avoir une
épée de Damoclès au dessus de la tête
bien sûr nous on était contre on était
complètement intégré on était scolarisés
et nos parents nous disaient très très
régulièrement
que notre vie n'était pas là que qu'on a
qu'on retournerait vivre en Algérie et
nous on vivait ça comme comme une
angoisse mais le fait d'avoir une
aspiration différente de celle de vos
parents vous aviez pas l'impression de
trahir un peu leur propre rêve non pas
du tout pas du tout on n'avait pas pas
ce sentiment parce que en même temps nos
parents nous encouragaient à nous
intégrer à travailler très bien ils
avaient beaucoup d'ambition pour nous il
souhaitaient vraiment qu'on réussisse
dans notre vie
familiale scolaire et alors vous êtes
vous n'êtes pas la seule dans votre
famille à avoir eu un engagement
politique votre père aussi sauf que
c'est quelque chose que vous avez
découvert vraiment très tardivement
c'est ça oui je l'ai découvert très
tardivement son engagement politique
même si dans à la maison on parlait très
très souvent politique je savais que mes
parents étaient très intéressés par la
politique et je l'ai et je l'ai
découvert
de manière assez furtive c'est à dire
que je on sentait qu'il y avait quelque
chose
on sentait qu'il s'était passé quelque
chose parce que c'est il y avait tout
une période de
la vie de mon père ça restait dans le
secret et je l'ai découvert suite à une
commémoration du 17 octobre 61 je rentre
à la maison et
au cours de laquelle beaucoup
d'Algériens sont morts ont été tués dont
mon père a participé mais enfin il
voulait y aller mais il avait été arrêté
à la porte de Pantin et donc j'arrive
chez moi il y avait un journaliste
Sébastien Pasco qui travaillait sur
justement les événements du 17 octobre
et qui étaient venus rencontrer mon père
pour pour un témoignage pour faire pour
faire un documentaire sur cette période
assez obscure et
de là il est les discussions et donc
vous avez découvert qu'il était engagé
au sein du n en France mais que c'est un
engagement qui visiblement est allé
assez loin parce qu'il a été arrêté même
torturé par la police française sur le
territoire en métropole oui alors oui
c'était engagé politiquement je pense
qu'il devait participer à des réunions
secrètes du FLN je pense qu'il devait
aussi tracter c'était une période qui
était assez compliquée parce qu'il y
avait un couvre-feu et il a été arrêté
arrêté par la police française
il nous en a pas dit grand-chose on
sentait beaucoup beaucoup de souffrance
dans dans ce qui nous relatait nous a
juste dit qu'il avait vécu la pire nuit
de sa vie
et il nous a juste dit je n'y rentrerai
pas dans les détails mais on a tous
compris que c'était qu'il avait été
torturé et il a été libéré le lendemain
matin le lendemain matin certainement
enfin grâce ce qui nous a dit à un
policier qui était très bienveillant et
qui l'a libéré en secret et de là quand
il a quitté le commissariat il a fui il
a fui parce qu'il était inquiété il
avait été fortement inquiété il a fui et
il est allé se réfugier en Belgique
votre père il s'est battu donc pour
l'indépendance de l'Algérie vous êtes
vous aujourd'hui une députée qui
représente la nation française ça fait
deux trajectoires opposées vous y pensez
à ça souvent
j'y pense très très souvent surtout que
mon père n'ait plus de ce monde il nous
a quitté pendant pendant le covid il a
fait partie de ces gens qui sont des
personnes qui sont décédées dans
seul dans les maisons mais j'y pense
très très souvent et je me dis qu'il
doit être très très fier de moi c'est à
dire il aurait été fier de vous voir
porter les charges tricolore il était
déjà quand j'étais mère adjoint parce
que je l'ai été pendant 12 ans il a été
vraiment très très fier on en parlait
très très souvent à la maison il me
disait toujours de faire attention voilà
il avait toujours peur de mon engagement
à une autre forme d'engagement
alors tous les chemins mènent à la
politique vous l'avez dit vous vous avez
été engagé Logan localement à La
Courneuve ce qui a déclenché cet
engagement politique c'est tout
simplement parce que vous étiez parents
d'élèves et vous avez été repéré par
l'équipe municipale de l'époque qui vous
a convaincu de se présenter de vous
présenter sur la liste vous êtes devenu
adjointe à la culture en
2008 mais au début vous avez refusé de
prendre votre carte au Parti communiste
la municipalité était communiste
pourquoi alors c'était pas un refuser
c'est que je voulais simplement pas
m'encarter dans un parti politique je
considérais que être personnalité
citoyenne enfin j'avais toute ma place
dans dans ce conseil municipal et je ne
voulais pas m'encarter et cet engagement
fondamentalement il est lié à ce
département où vous avez toujours vécu
la Seine-Saint-Denis c'est c'est dans
cette idée de servir sa population pour
moi il était très important de rester
dans le département qui qui m'a presque
vu naître même si je finis à Ghazaouet
où vous avez enseigné pendant longtemps
dans en collège notamment avec des
élèves en difficulté pour moi c'était
primordial de rester dans ce dans ce
département qui qui est un département
qui a un énorme potentiel qui est un
département où ça foisonne de culture de
social etc mais qui aussi cumulent
toutes les difficultés et j'avais le
sentiment de servir de servir à quelque
chose c'est pour ça que je suis resté
quand j'étais enseignante toujours dans
le 93 l'idée de vous rendre utile à la
population exactement alors quand on
fait de la politique à La Courneuve
forcément on croise le chemin de
Marie-Georges Buffet à un moment ou un
autre vous avez vous avez été sa
suppléante en 2017 et en 2002 2022 vous
avez échangé les rôles c'est elle qui
est devenu votre propre suppléante vous
partagez les mêmes combats à la fois
pour les droits des femmes et pour le
sport et c'est ce qui a motivé
d'ailleurs une question que vous avez
posée au ministre de l'Intérieur au mois
de novembre dernier on va en revoir un
extrait
avec Marie-George Buffet nous avons
alerté à de nombreuses reprises sur le
sort des sept joueuses de l'équipe
nationale afghane de handball réfugiés
depuis de nombreux mois à Islamabad ou
Pakistan pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre me préciser quand des visas
leur seront attribués dès que cela sera
possible dans les meilleures moments et
dans les façons les plus sécurisées pour
elles ne pourrons non seulement en
délivrer des deux séjours et contribuer
à leur appartement sur le territoire de
la République alors c'est handbaleuses
elles sont aujourd'hui en France c'était
un combat qui avait porté Marie-Georges
Buffet jusqu'en 2022 que vous avez
repris et qui a abouti concrètement ça
veut dire que quand on est député de
l'opposition on peut quand même faire
aboutir des des combats politiques à
l'Assemblée et heureusement heureusement
on est quand même quelques fois
utile donc c'est vrai que j'attache
beaucoup d'importance à ce combat parce
qu'il a lit vraiment le sport et le
combat féministe en fait c'était des
femmes qui étaient
inquiétées dans leur pays en Afghanistan
et qui se sont réfugiés au Pakistan et
elles sont arrivées juste avant les
fêtes de Noël d'ailleurs je les ai
rencontrés à plusieurs reprises et je
dois les inviter à l'assembler dès la
fin du ramadan on suivra ça on va passer
à notre quiz à présent si vous le voulez
bien donc je vous explique le principe
je vais commencer des phrases et ce sera
à vous de les finir de les compléter on
va dire on y va quand je suis arrivé à
l'Assemblée le plus dur a été
de comprendre
tout ce qui était juridique voilà parce
que la feuille blanche la feuille jaune
la feuille verte pardon la motion de
censure à quel moment on peut la faire
la Constitution je crois que là c'était
vraiment très très compliqué pour moi
mais bon j'ai été très
du groupe j'ai eu des collègues dans mon
groupe qui épuisent les collaborateurs
et collaboratrices qui ont été d'une
aide incroyable parfois je me dis que ma
suppléante pourrait quand même
oui ça se fait pas comme ça mais en
effet c'est vrai que il faudrait quand
même se reposer la question de du rôle
du support qui est un peu invisible pas
dans mon cas pas dans le cas de
Marie-Georges Buffet puisque c'est une
personne qui est qui est mondialement
connue de rester très présente j'imagine
sur le terrain exactement qui qui est
toujours avec moi et qui tracte avec moi
et qui reste une militante
acharnée s'il y a un combat que je
souhaite faire aboutir pendant ce mandat
c'est alors il y en a plusieurs mais il
est vrai que il y en a un qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur c'est celui de
du vote des étrangers aux élections
municipales en effet je trouve que il
serait très intéressant de pouvoir
permettre à ces gens issus de
l'immigration après voir comment sur
combien d'années mais peut-être voilà y
réfléchir et faire cette
des simples ressortissants de l'Union
Européenne exactement parce que oui en
effet vous avez raison de de le
souligner les Européens ont le droit de
vote mais les autres non et je pense que
ça serait vraiment une véritable avancée
démocratique merci beaucoup Soumia
Bourgois d'être venu dans la politique
et moi c'était un plaisir
merci
[Musique]